[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález
en esta oportunidad dejamos de lado la
actualidad política internacional para
hablar de los acontecimientos deportivos
recientes en el mundo deportivo
hablaremos de ese torbellino de
especulaciones y emociones incertidumbre
que comenzó el 5 de agosto cuando se
hizo oficial el retiro de lionel messi
del barça sólo cinco días después el 10
de agosto los seguidores de messi ya
respiraban más tranquilos el astro
argentino anunció su ficha por el psg
francés los catalanes y los españoles
por supuesto lloraron su partida
mientras que en parís los ánimos están
por las nubes inalcanzables así fueron
los hechos se lo contamos en el
siguiente reportaje
después de neymar mbappe y más
recientemente sergio ramos leo messi se
une a las filas del parís saint germain
atrás quedaron las lágrimas tras partir
del barcelona en su primera conferencia
de prensa como miembro del equipo
confesó su alegría de estar en la
capital francesa y reiteró su ambición
de más títulos bueno con muchísima
ilusión como ghana que que nunca
muchas veces lo dije mi mi objetivo y mi
sueño de poder volver a levantar otra
champions messi estuvo acompañado por
nacer al khelaifi presidente del club
quien respondió así cuando le
preguntaron por el fair play financiero
la norma que regula los gastos de los
equipos europeos
seguimos la normativa del fair play
financiero desde el primer día que
empezamos y hasta el final siempre
cumpliremos esta normativa antes de
hacer cualquier cosa básicamente miramos
con nuestros consejeros financieros
comerciales y legales informar sobre
bowling el club
y mientras tanto en las calles desde muy
temprano la fila para ingresar a la
tienda oficial del club se perdía de
vista los aficionados no esperaron para
disputarse las nuevas camisetas con el
nombre del astro argentino la máscara de
165 euros
casi dos horas es mucho tiempo pero
estamos contentos ya lo logramos al fin
podemos tener nuestra recompensa
messi no puso fecha para su debut con
los colores del psg según el astro
argentino tiene que realizar una
pretemporada propia para ponerse a punto
después de un mes de vacaciones tras
haber ganado la copa américa con su
selección
[Música]
bueno quedan muchas preguntas sobre la
mesa por ejemplo la verdadera situación
económica del club barça que no pudo en
palabras de su propio presidente
garantizar el sueldo anual de messi por
la situación financiera que está
presentando el club dice en ellos que es
una herencia de la antigua
administración también se habla de la
estrategia del psg señalado de tener una
obsesión por ganar la liga de campeones
el torneo de fútbol europeo más
prestigioso y también de una supuesta
estrategia de los dueños del psg que es
el emirato de qatar que a través de un
fondo de inversión deportiva está siendo
señalado de querer mejorar la imagen de
qatar en el mundo ante las constantes
denuncias y críticas por violaciones a
los derechos humanos y también por esa
adjudicación de la sede del mundial de
fútbol del 2022 como ven puede ser un
tema deportivo pero el tema de hoy de
debate no escapa del acontecer de la
geopolítica internacional y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a una
planilla pues de primer nivel como tiene
que ser en estos casos y está con
nosotros cristina cubero ella
subdirectora del diario español el mundo
deportivo se encuentra en barcelona allí
en plena ola de calor y en pleno verano
boreal también está con nosotros luis
ferrer de lf 360 puntocom también ex
directivo del parís saint germain él se
encuentra en la ciudad de niza en el sur
de francia y está con nosotros aquí en
el estudio de france 24 sara castro
directora del diario online deportivo
'as' colombia ustedes también son
partícipes de este debate pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios ser partícipes de
la conversación a través de las redes
sociales ustedes pueden dejar los
comentarios y preguntas en nuestras
cuentas en facebook y también en twitter
y en instagram estamos como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
dejen los comentarios con el numeral el
debate efe 24 allí pueden dejar todos
sus comentarios y preguntas sobre este
tema pues comienzo preguntándole a
christina en la ciudad de barcelona las
primeras impresiones para ir tanteando
opiniones sobre este tema christina su
opinión sobre el paso de messi del
barcelona en las circunstancias que ya
sabemos que rodearon este y su llegada
al psg
bueno estoy hablando de que es la playa
donde vivía leo messi hasta hace una
semana donde ha vivido los últimos 21
años de su vida y donde no quería
marcharse porque las lágrimas de messi
cuando se despedía del barcelona no era
no era tanto por dejar el club como por
dejar su estilo de vida aquí en
barcelona en la playa que hace de elx su
vida cómoda sus hijos estaban en la
escuela su mujer estaba totalmente
adaptada en lo dejó clarísimo él no
tardaría en adaptarse al parís saint
germain su familiar y ccoo sería un poco
más tú hablas de geopolítica obvio
queremos hablar de geopolítica en este
caso porque lamentablemente al barça
este último año y medio la crisis del
cob y que ha afectado globalmente a todo
el mundo le ha le ha dejado sin ingresar
prácticamente 550 millones de euros el
año pasado dejó de ingresar 365 millones
de euros por la no venta obviamente de
ticketing y por todos los activos
que genera en el estadio es decir el
barça tiene un museo que es el museo más
estado por ejemplo la gente que visita
su camisa supone un ingreso
importantísimo cuantificado toda esta
falta de ingresos derivan una cantidad
de 365 millones de euros el año pasado y
este año presupuestado dejará ingresar
300 millones es que significa que ha
dejado de estar más de 150 millones de
euros qatar el equipo qatarí el parís
saint germain no tiene problemas porque
todo el dinero proviene de fuera del
fútbol es decir hay dos equipos que son
equipos estados que sobre el manchester
city y el parís saint germain que no
tienen problemas para ingresar dinero de
cualquier parte porque su dinero no
proviene el fútbol yo creo que esos dos
equipos no tenían que participar en la
misma competición que el resto de
equipos europeos porque no siguen las
mismas reglas del juego porque el barça
germain ha solventado un contrato de
messi en dos días claro cómo es posible
que un equipo que tiene a neymar y tiene
a empape entre otros jugadores pueda
hacer un contrato a un juan como leo
messi que pasará a cobrar en el
presentador 200 millones de euros en dos
días porque porque su dinero no proviene
el mundo del fútbol claro ahora pasamos
a luís ferrer en la ciudad de niza para
conocer su opinión adelante louis
hola que tal buenas tardes a todos un
gusto estar no sé si me escuchan sin
perfecta opciones adelante
muy bien muy bien saludo también a
christina creo que está ahí en el sur
que también que hace calor veo aquí en
misa también mucho calor pero que
externa plan ya me imagino así que
disfrutando así que bueno ante todo un
saludo y bueno para responder un poquito
a lo que puedo opinar como trabajé 11
años en el fútbol el parís saint germain
me ocupaba precisamente en la parte
deportiva o sea que salía ahora en
diciembre del año pasado o sea que estoy
bien informado de el tema las
contrataciones y todo y es correcto que
el cover ha hecho daño totalmente al
fútbol mundial como a todo a todo
sistema
por eso yo pienso que se hizo posible
esta salida de messi porque como explicó
bien cristina no tenía la capacidad
barcelona de poder aguantar un contrato
a messi y en este caso como no está
funcionando el fair play financiero a
100% porque es verdad que lo que dijo
christina por eso se creó el fair play
financiero para que solamente los
equipos grandes como el manchester
united el par 2 manchester city- piques
de abu dhabi parís el germen que de
qatar que con esto simplemente pueden
gastar lo que generan ese es un poco y
ahora por culpa del hobbit que no está
funcionando pudo sumar esencialmente que
abrió los brazos el fútbol francés el
gobierno francés no es solamente parecen
armen es todo un país atrás que lo
recibe con los brazos abiertos y
lamentablemente no puedo
y hablar del sistema si también si está
mal yo no no no no entro en esa en ese
debate yo solamente estoy comentando el
por qué entra en parís por cómo es como
el aro qué es lo que sucedió que fue
solamente osea que es un poco la lo que
todo el mundo lo vivió que vimos que que
lo dijo bien claramente leonel messi una
conferencia de prensa donde le hizo en
barcelona que lamentablemente el año
pasado estaba preparado para poder
salir el año pasado cuando el mismo me
dio la noticia que quería salir esta vez
lo dijo bien claro que no quería salir
que quería volver lamentablemente es
como que lo pusieron en la calle fue el
sentimiento que nos dio a entender a
todos y por supuesto que el país
incialmente con la capacidad que tiene y
que no sabemos todos no dudó un minuto
de contactar con de contactarnos y de
traernos y esa es la opinión que
comparten muchos fanáticos y seguidores
del barça tanto en cataluña en barcelona
como en otras partes del mundo sara su
opinión para el cierre de esta primera
ronda de opiniones para conocer
impresiones sobre este tema antes que
nada gracias por la invitación un saludo
para todos para mí esta situación se
puede leer en tres claves la primera un
nuevo orden del fútbol mundial que tiene
mucho que ver con el soft pauer con ese
poder de la cultura y lo que quiere
hacer catar digamos a nivel
internacional y que ha encontrado en el
fútbol un vehículo muy importante pero
también estamos hablando de un nuevo
orden mundial en el fútbol no siempre ha
habido clubes poderosos ahora los
llamamos la atención cuáles son los
nuevos poderosos por otro lado esta
situación nos pone en perspectiva de lo
que significa leonel messi como figura a
nivel de fútbol él nunca ha tenido una
presentación de estas y esto nos pone en
perspectiva de su figura y lo que
hubiera podido generarse en algún
momento cuando empiezan estas
transferencias y a vivirse el fútbol de
esta manera y creo que también le
correspondía y fue muy interesante ver
eso no hay ese paralelo que siempre
solemos hacer con la llegada de maradona
nápoles y su llegada ahora a parís y en
tercer lugar desde el punto de vista
deportivo y esto lo sabe muy bien luis
este es un proyecto que se ha venido
trabajando desde hace diez años y que no
siempre juntar a los mejores de los
reflex el excelente resultado y creo que
ahí vamos a tener un reto muy
interesante para el entrenador para
mauricio pochetino
porque tener esas figuras y hacerlas
funcionar también es clave y cuando se
habla de deporte siempre es interesante
eso no cómo se logran resultados a
partir del convencimiento y cómo se
logran encajar esas fichas además
teniendo claro que con messi ya el reto
es ganar la champions league sí o sí
como sea ese es el reto y la obsesión
del psg a toda costa sara sigo con usted
para hacer la ronda a la inversa
puede aportarle mes y al psg que es lo
que deja el atrás o que falencias tiene
este equipo mejor para hablar primero el
mensaje antes de hablar de lo que queda
en el barça hablemos de lo que él se va
a encontrar qué tipo de equipo va a
encontrar el hay en el psg y que pueda
aportar el al psg es un equipo lleno de
figuras yo creo que diría que tiene los
mejores jugadores del mundo neymar y
messi y luego está empape que es la gran
promesa porque ya es presente no aún
pendientes de lo que pueda pasar con su
posible fichaje a otro club qué es lo
que pasa con messi que es un jugador ya
maduro es un jugador que ha sabido
adaptar sus capacidades a su juego
porque es un jugador que llega al paris
saint german en una época de su carrera
en la que cuenta su inteligencia y esa
adaptación y creo que lo que aprendió y
lo tenemos en un contexto súper cercano
en la copa américa lionel scaloni en la
argentina es que el equipo no tenga que
depender de él que el aporte al equipo y
que el equipo la rompe pero no en una
estructura en donde todo el juego pase
por ahí
va a tener muchos retos a nivel
internacional ya se conoce el juego y
sobre todo esa jerarquía que es
necesaria para conseguir resultados el
bien aportar eso creo que para animar
también va a ser un socio muy importante
le va a dar yo creo que otras otros
entornos para que él también desarrolle
su juego y además una serie de jugadores
que no están en este top of mine de la
gente como los más grandes pero que
también hacen una estructura interesante
entonces que deja deja 35 títulos en el
barça y ahora la ilusión de poder
aportarle a este proyecto del que ya
hemos hablado que es un travestido
etcétera la posibilidad de ganar títulos
louis en la ciudad de niza le guste que
conoce el interior del psg lo conoce
como la palma de su mano cómo se
encuentra este equipo en este momento
futbolísticamente hablando
bueno eres en este momento
primero de todo en una emoción
fantástica o terrible una emoción de los
jugadores dentro del vestuario porque
es verdad que una semana atrás nadie se
imaginaba que iba a llegar a leo messi
así que no se vivió y por suerte se
encuentra leo se va a encontrar con
vestuario sano quiere decir que hay un
vestuario con chicos hay un buen grupo
se habla español para porque les voy a
dar el ejemplo de khyria en el papel
como pueden saber bueno participe a la
avenida o sea que trabaje para que se
haga lo posible la habilidad de mónaco a
parís o sea que conozco bien los
detalles y para hablar hasta el mismo
habla español o sea que se va a
encontrar con un vestuario que es que a
la mañana está el mate es una tradición
argentina ya que yo veo que está todo
dado para que se encuentre lo mejor
posible sabemos que barcelona en su casa
pero pero esta experiencia yo creo que
le va a hacer
si lo va a tratar de una manera que él
mismo va estar solo sorprendido porque
hay que saber con otra cultura rafa
francia es un país no es la misma no
tiene la misma
aparte del idioma pero eso tiene en
otras cosas pero dentro del fútbol iffhs
y el otro punto a remarcables es el
staff el entrenador es mauricio
pochettino que es argentino y su staff
tuvo donde equipo así que yo creo que
mejor en condiciones listas no se le
pueden brindar un entorno favorecedor
para messi christina le pregunto ahora
por el entorno que deja atrás messi en
el barcelona tal parece que deja un
equipo muy afectado por su retiro
obviamente así lo han evidenciado bueno
me dicen que vamos a retomar la conexión
con cristina en unos minutos allí en el
castelldefels en la costa catalana más
adelante entonces le preguntaremos sobre
lo que deja allí mes y cómo queda la
condición financiera del barça la
situación con
las autoridades me confirman que ahí
está ya con nosotros cristina perfecto
cristina retomó la pregunta entonces
quería preguntarle qué es lo que queda
entonces del barça sin messi vemos en
situación financiera complicada unos una
fanaticada completamente entristecida y
una despedida poco habitual no hubiera
sido la que el mismo mes y quería que
fuera su despedida del barça el mismo lo
dijo le hubiera gustado un estadio
completamente lleno de fanáticos
cantando su nombre si lamentablemente él
hace un año sí que quiso marcharse en el
barça y entonces estaba preparado para
hacerlo esta vez no estaba preparado
para dejar el barça bueno pero al vaso
lo que le queda ese es la época post mes
y que tarde o temprano tenía que llegar
podría ser este año de aquí dentro de
dos años cuando tenía pensado en
marcharse del barça pues le queda a
chavales de la cantera de jugadores como
one shufat y como gaby como pedrique que
apunta muy buenas maneras y tiene que
pagar la reconstrucción de este equipo
basándose en lo que se basó hace 15 años
que es la gente de la cantera al final
leo messi y yo con 13 años al barça el
barça le dio la posibilidad de curarse
de su enfermedad lo mismo hizo un equipo
para él y como gente de la cantera como
xavi como iniesta como busquets como
puyol y esa esa forma de ser del barça
va a continuar siendo así va a continuar
confiando en gente joven formada con los
valores del barça y con el estilo de
juego del barça y seguramente de aquí a
15 años tenemos hablando o antes quizás
de un nuevo mes y un nuevo horno al niño
nuevo romario un nuevo rival
no creáis porque es que eres del barça
te pones a repasar la historia y menos
pelea jugado todos y siempre pensábamos
no llegar a otro mejor de cruyff y llegó
a ronaldinho no llegará otra mejor
ronaldinho llegó meses y nos llegará
otro mejor que messi seguramente llegará
otro jugador que nos hará recordar que
el fútbol es grande por eso por lo
cíclico que es christina sobre la mesa
quedó otra vez y sucede cada vez que se
dan estos estas transferencias de los de
los jugadores en los grandes equipos de
fútbol y son los salarios básicamente el
barça no pudo amortizar la cifra que era
considerada se le debía pagar a messi
después de todos estos años de estar
allí y por eso pues se da su retiro no
es por por su propia iniciativa
digámoslo de esa manera vuelve a quedar
sobre la mesa estos salarios
astronómicos que se le están pagando a
los futbolistas messi tenía necesidad de
ganar eso con toda la fortuna que tiene
simplemente por el gusto de quedarse en
el barça no podía haberse quedado
ganando algo mínimo y seguir jugando con
los suyos usted cómo lo ve
eso es lo que planteó desde el principio
cuando todo se rompió yo dije a ver si
realmente leo messi quiere quedarse en
barcelona si es un casa desde hace 21
años si piensa en la felicidad de su
familia que más está jugar un año gratis
el siguiente ya veremos cómo ha hecho
pau gasol con el baloncesto del de
barcelona hemos vivido el mismo caso
pero realmente leo messi es una máquina
de generar dinero lo ha sido siempre
durante esos últimos años el barça lo
convirtió en el mejor pagado con mucha
diferencia de hecho a cobrar el barça
dos veces más que neymar él le parece
bien men ahora va a seguir siendo el
mejor jugador del mundo el mejor pagado
del mundo porque va a cobrar 5 millones
más de euros que neymar y no se
contemplaba en su entorno en sus
abogados y su padre la posibilidad de
que no generar esas cantidades
descomunales de dinero no de hecho iba a
cobrar 200 millones de euros del barça
por los próximos cinco años de contrato
aunque sólo va a jugar dos en el futuro
barcelona estamos hablando de que el
barça convirtió a leo messi repito en el
jugador mejor pagado 3 que doblaba el
sueldo
he pagado con tanto dinero como te ha
hecho ingresar de barcelona yo me
preguntaba por qué no hace ese gesto con
los aficionados del barça que llevan un
año y medio sin ver el futuro en directo
porque como en todo el mundo no se
pueden trade los estadios y han sufrido
esta situación porque no regalarles en
gratitud o devolver la gratitud y jugar
a un año gratis bueno eso no lo
contemplaron no estaba en los cánones de
ellas no estuvo dentro de las
posibilidades tal parece que no
facilitará opinión sobre este tema de
los salarios sobre esto que estamos
planteando que quemes y pues ya es una
persona suficientemente adinerada tiene
su vida organizada digámoslo así sus
inversiones ha sabido manejar sus
ganancias era necesario que se tuviera
que retirar por no ganarse tantos
millones no sé si la respuesta de messi
tiene que ver con poder dejar de ganar o
no porque evidentemente su vida está
solucionada pero creo que él tampoco
tenía que hacerse cargo de los problemas
que dejó el ex presidente del barcelona
todas esas deudas no son una
consecuencia de meses nuevo a
consecuencia de las haría gestiones que
no corresponden con lo que los tiempos
pedían entendiendo también que la crisis
pues género otras complicaciones
adicionales y yo entiendo que el fútbol
está muy vinculado con las emociones y
siempre queremos eso del agradecimiento
pero no es él el que tiene que
solucionarlo todo
y creo que en ese sentido al final estos
termina siendo un negocio y el negocio
del fútbol sigue moviendo mucho dinero y
el barcelona más allá del agradecimiento
de messi también todos estos años ha
podido su fractura lo que él genera en
el fútbol y creo que la pregunta que
queda es qué tan golpeado a quedar la
liga española con la salida de lionel
messi no
javier tebas está el presidente de la
liga acción predicho que se construye la
competitividad por encima de los nombres
y que no va a generar pero una liga sin
primero cristiano ronaldo que se va a
italia y ahora sin mes y creo que esto
va a poner a empezar a poner en la
balanza sobre esos pesos y sobre todo lo
que desea cristina y es barcelona tiene
que empezar a construir esos nuevos
mitos no esas nuevas figuras que sigan
llevando gente a la calle que siga
manteniendo pues todas rica historia y
lo que lo ha tenido como uno de los
clubes más importantes del mundo
complemento lo que usted dice sara
durante el 2017 del 2020 esto es un
estudio realizado
en españa' leonel messi logró que el
equipo recibiera más de 600 millones de
euros en concepto de mercadeo de visitas
al estadio de entradas a los partidos
camisetas productos de merchandising
derechos de televisión y eventos porque
simplemente lo querían seguir y también
generó un fue uno de los puntos que
ayudó a generar mayor tráfico de
visitantes procedentes de asia hacia la
capital catalana porque venían desde
china japón corea taiwán a visitar
barcelona para ver los partidos allí en
la capital catalana louis quiero que
hablemos ahora del otro lado de la
moneda el psg ya hemos hablado y hemos
dado algunos puntos de la estrategia de
este equipo gracias a la inyección
financiera que está recibiendo de sus
inversionistas de qatar que le da un
músculo económico que le permite hacer
este tipo de transacciones y envidiadas
por muchos equipos pero pues bueno ahí
la tienen y tienen que aprovecharla como
es esta estrategia a que le están
apuntando ellos y qué es lo que ellos
quieren lograr en el futuro próximo
solo lo único que puedo hablar de ese
tema
yo vivía dentro el club está funcionando
con el presidente que efectivamente de
qatar que está muy involucrado en lo que
es la liga 1 en la liga 1 de francia por
un director deportivo que leonardo que
está a cargo de todo lo deportivo son
ellos las personas que están manejando
lo lo lo del día a día todas
nosotros posible que gana la champions
liga con el tema tu pregunta belén de la
fuerza que tiene qatar para meter el
dinero en
actualmente parece realmente como en
todos los equipos de francia está un
control descripción que antes comienza
la temporada uno tiene que mostrar lo
que es no el presupuesto y con
eso se se hace el equipo o sea que uno
tiene el equipo el presupuesto y ahí se
hace en el alrededor por qué por qué no
lo mismo hace el equipo personalmente el
equipo de lyon que mónaco
que otros equipos más pequeños o sea que
todo se adapta después si le aparece la
mente en esa capacidad como en este
momento de poder aumentar
aumentar el presupuesto porque ahora lo
va a tener que aumentar por la llegada
bueno como yo dije recién
en la suerte que tiene en parís en
realmente tener a alguien atrás
estar que lo está está apoyándolo para
poder lograr su objetivo
christina pasó a preguntarle por este
controvertido tema de un club estado ya
lo mencionábamos tiene un financiamiento
de este fondo de inversión del emirato
de qatar muy criticado también muy
envidiado por otros equipos que
envidiarían tener esas inversiones para
poder comprar jugadores de altísimo
nivel su opinión sobre este tema sobre
estas críticas está el psg en una
instancia superior a la del resto de
equipos de la liga francesa y de la liga
europea
bueno sin duda tanto tanto
como el manchester city en juegan con
las cartas marcadas bajo mi punto de
vista al final cuando cuando dinero que
tú
utilizas para comprar jugadores no
proviene sólo de una familia qatarí sino
que proviene de otros sponsors
vinculados también a qatar es decir al
final si les falta un sponsor siempre
hay alguna empresa
familiar
de la familia real catarí que invertirá
con el dinero del petróleo y el gas
natural en un club de fútbol por tanto
no es que tú generes como es como el
barça que era el club que generaba más
ingresos pero de forma natural con él
por allá del cob y deja de ingresar ese
dinero y viene la crisis dentro de
dentro del club no pero porque se basaba
todo en un modelo empresarial de gestión
empresarial dentro del fútbol
saint germain el dinero no proviene
exclusivamente dentro del fútbol por eso
para mí las cartas están marcadas pero
las reales que para ese viernes funciona
así desde hace tiempo y el año pasado
por ejemplo no ganó ni la liga o sea al
final no te garantiza tener a comprar a
jugadores a golpe de talonario como
hicieron con neymar que pagarán 222
millones de euros con la cláusula de
recisión eso no te garantiza a ganar
títulos vamos a ver qué pasa qué pasa
ahora sí juntando cracks como hizo el
real madrid de los 'galácticos' le pasa
como le pasó al real madrid florentino
pérez que no ganó ningún título
importante pese a tener las grandes
figuras no
y sarah opiniones por este lado en torno
a este tema de las inversiones del fair
play financiero que ya lo mencionamos al
principio
se está generando hay un desbalance en
la liga francesa y en la liga europea
sin duda hay un desbalance y es
imposible no estar de acuerdo con lo que
ya planteó cristina en ese sentido desde
el punto de vista deportivo yo creo que
por eso sí ya estamos hablando de un
nuevo orden de las cosas porque también
hubo clubes antes que tuvieron a los
mejores del mundo cristiano mencionaba a
los galácticos el milan en algún momento
también tuvo a los mejores jugadores del
mundo y por eso son poderosos y por eso
se convirtieron en clubes importantes
que cuando el mercado cambia y esto
empieza a ser un negocio global empiezan
a generar fanáticos alrededor del mundo
más allá de eso hay que decir y ya lo
mencionaba luis y es que cuando uno mira
los gastos netos en fichajes del paris
saint german están muy abajo en el
ranking entonces independientemente de
donde provengan los ingresos y
entendiendo que esto es como un doping
digamos financiero en el sentido en que
hay muchísimos recursos para invertir
ellos sí siguen acogiéndose a los reglas
y entiendo la diferenciación que hace
cristina de un dinero que proviene del
negocio netamente de fútbol a tener una
cantidad de empresas o de compañías que
van los gastos pero creo que al final de
cuentas si estamos hablando de eso es un
orden del fútbol mundial que ya lo
estamos viendo con qatar como sede
además del mundial de la fifa que es
algo que además ha buscado la fifa
dentro de un modelo entre comillas de
democratización del fútbol y es el resto
del mundo también tiene derecho mucho
mejor si son los que tienen plata los
que pueden hacer que el fútbol llegue a
otros lugares soporta la gran inversión
pero este cambio ya se ha dado nos al
final la televisión empezó a transmitir
partidos en horarios de asia y en
horarios de mercados que no eran los
tradicionales entonces
independientemente de que nosotros
tengamos un vínculo emocional a una
manera de ver el fútbol esto es lo que
estamos viviendo y que ojalá dentro de
las condiciones de la uefa y en general
de la fifa pues que sea lo más
justo posible pero ahora vamos a ver
deportivamente cómo funciona este parís
saint germain que es el próximo reto ese
es el próximo reto louis ya me quedan
pocos minutos del programa quiero
preguntarle que podemos esperar en la
estrategia del psg a futuro nuevos
jugadores tal vez cristiano ronaldo
uniéndose a las filas del psg alguna
transacción de este tipo usted cómo lo
ve está y también le pregunto cuándo
podría estar mes y empezando a jugar
porque llevaba un mes sin poder entrenar
nacho yo pienso que hoy fue su primer
día viene de jugar la copa américa donde
fue muy
eufórico con la victoria entonces bueno
ahora hay que prepararlo bien lo que me
gustó que viene con hambre de ganar
títulos lo dijo bien claro él quiere
llegar a dani alves o pasarlo la nieve
tiene 43 sino bien sí recuerdo títulos
consagrados leo que ser 46 a lo mejor se
todo pero bueno pero lo nombró sé que
viene y lo sé dentro de dentro del
parece realmente se nota que tiene esas
ganas de venir para para lograr más
títulos sabemos que en parís
puede llegar a aumentar esas
palmas con subtítulos que tiene que
estar así que bueno solo lo veo que veo
que está
con una sensación de como un chico
cuando cuando viene un jugador a un
equipo nuevo porque sabemos que messi ya
ganó todos los meses y es algo es el
mejor jugador del mundo y notarlo como
me están diciendo realmente lo notan con
una ansiedad con ganas así que estoy
estoy ansioso no también de verlo como
como cómo va a poder
desenvolverse como toda la como todo el
pueblo fácil bears
christina para el cierre el complemento
lo que estaba diciendo luis muchas a
mucha ansiedad muchas ganas pero también
mucha presión va a estar bajo mucha
presión messi
bueno no está acostumbrado a vivir en
presión al final lleva muchos años en la
élite y además en el país el jiennense
encuentras encontrar a un equipo que va
a jugar para él es intimísimo de neymar
tiene un grupo de guasa para luis suárez
neymar y el y hablan carla van cada día
cuando está presente leo aquí tiene di
maría tiene mano monito de amigos aparte
de pollo de mauricio que es uno de los
nuestros que hizo toda su garra que el
espanyol de barcelona no lo tenía todo
fácil para triunfar lo único es que se
vivía muy bien en barcelona
él creció cobijado por el barça y ahora
por primera vez en su vida
empieza una aventura distinta fuera de
su círculo de confort vamos a ver cómo
se desarrollan lo normal es que con la
carrera que tiene el leo messi con el
acostumbrado que está a las grandes las
grandes citas triunfé pero no olvidemos
que los últimos tres años
lamentablemente el barcelona en los
partidos importantes con leo messi en el
campo el equipo tampoco ganaba
y para el cierre estar aquí en el
estudio de france 24 conclusión de toda
esta transacción ha mencionado usted a
lo largo del programa que estamos como
en el inicio un nuevo capítulo de la de
la industria de fútbol como tal a nivel
comercial y a nivel deportivo su
conclusión la gran conclusión de este
debate bueno en general que estamos
vamos a poder aprovechar a uno de los
mejores jugadores de fútbol del mundo en
un contexto totalmente diferente lo cual
activa también como ese interés por el
fútbol que parís va a tener una
atracción una nueva atracción turística
como si le faltara alguna y que eso
también es entendido como
parte de lo que les decía no de ese
poder de la cultura hoy en día y de como
el fútbol más que negocio más allá
genera un poder cultural muy importante
para para este tipo de inversores o sea
estas marcas que quieren hacer el
deporte y luego a nivel del fútbol es
cómo funciona esto no como cómo podemos
disfrutar venimos de una eurocopa
absolutamente interesante una copa
américa también interesante cómo empieza
a funcionar el fútbol de figuras que sin
duda marcará una época
guardarlo esto también en la memoria
pues ahora muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado hoy en el programa luis
ferrer en niza y a cristina cubero
también allí en la ciudad de barcelona
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y ustedes muchas gracias por
los comentarios y las preguntas a través
de redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]